be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life
stuff so as I continue to bring you guys
some DC related content what I want to
do is I want to get current you know
there are a lot of great stories that
have been going on in DC over the course
of its history we talked about Teen
Titans we've talked about Batman Beyond
we've talked about Harley Quinn but I
want to look at stuff that's going on
right now and specifically I want to
talk about Superman rebirth and the
reason why is because you know Superman
is the face of DC Comics he's one of the
most recognizable in the world and so it
makes sense that we would use this as
kind of a jumping off platform to begin
consistently providing DC content on the
channel and so with Superman rebirth
what I really like about this is it is
the quintessential example of what DC
rebirth means and what I mean here is
the whole idea of the Superman rebirth
not only comes out of the death of the
New 52 Superman but it comes out of the
pre-new 52 Superman and what I mean by
this is prior to or I guess when the new
52 launched people didn't really care
for the new Superman too much they were
curious to see what he was about But as
time progressed we saw that the New 52
Superman was emotional he was very human
in terms of how he functioned he let his
emotions get the best of him sometimes
he would get really angry he would freak
out there were times when he just was
not the Superman that we had come to
know from reading comics before the new
52 and so while there was some give and
take while there were some who loved him
some who didn't on the whole the vocal
minority was very very loud about what
it was they didn't like and so what DC
did is they gave us an event called
convergence
now convergence was very confusing to a
lot of people and so in order to make it
really really simple to understand
basically what DC had said was that all
the points in their history all the
major events in their history from
crisis on infinite Earth to you know
Zero Hour crisis in time some of the
major story ARS like Roy Harper people
finding out he was addicted to heroin
this was all these were all captured in
a bubble of sorts by the villain
Brainiac and it was just held in stasis
and so with convergence all these
realities were let loose and they all
just started fighting each other but for
a majority of these moments it was just
kind of a last Harrah it was just DC's
chance of saying hey guys here's your
last bite of the Apple here's your last
chance to to say goodbye to these
characters you're probably never going
to see him again but for Superman it was
a test it was a test bet it was the
question do people prefer the New 52
Superman over the pre- 52 Superman or
vice versa and so because people loved
the pre 52 Superman story as it was part
of convergence what DC did under Dan
Jurgens I think it was they gave us
super Superman Lois and Clark and this
story was done by virtue of what's
called a retcon now for those of you
guys who don't know what retcon is that
stands for retroactive continuity and
what it means is that a a coming book
publisher will create something and then
use that thing to alter the history of
their Comics so the pre New 52 Superman
is a really good example when
convergence ended the various
superheroes who had been part of that
event were offered the option to either
go back to their own realities to their
own timelines or to go somewhere new and
so what ended up happening is the pre
new 52 Superman his wife Lois and I
think their child was unborn at the time
ended up in the modern day they ended up
in the new 52 the beginning of that
continuity we didn't know this when the
new 52 first launched when the new 52
first started in 2011 we just got the
New 52 Superman Wonder Woman Aquaman
Batman Green Lantern cyborg so on they
came together as the Justice League they
fought dark side in their first six
issues and things just continued on
along their normal Stories the reccon
came into play when Superman Lois Clark
revealed that when conversions ended the
New 52 Superman ended up at the
beginning of the new 52 and he had seen
everything he was there he was watching
on when the Justice League first fought
dark side and this is where DC rebirth
really comes into play because for those
of us who are reading before the new 52
for those of us who preferred things
before the new 52 the pre- new52
Superman was our eyes and ears when he
stood on and he watched the Justice
League who were composed of superheroes
that he knew but were different
variations of the ones he knew it was us
watching characters that we were not
familiar with going against the villain
that we were familiar with when Superman
said that he had fought dark side on
countless occasions and knew how to
defeat him but wanted to see if the new
Justice League could do it it was us as
readers watching alongside Superman when
those events unfolded because in the pre
New 52 we'd seen where Superman had
fought dark side on countless occasions
on a multitude of occasions and defeated
him every single time and so it was a
way for us to relate to what was going
on in the new f it was basically a way
for us to stand in the new 52 and to say
okay you know we are basically this pre-
new52 Superman we are in a new universe
that we don't really understand that we
don't really know anything about that
has characters that are like the ones we
know but they're different at the same
time now fast forward to the end of the
new 52 of course the New 52 Superman
died and there's a whole another series
on that and I could probably do a video
on it if you guys are interested but
suffices to say when DC came along with
DC rebirth the the idea was take what
worked and blend it with the new 52 and
so they basically gave us the the pre-
new52 Superman as the current Superman
as the Superman that exists right now
now in terms of Superman rebirth the
actual Standalone issue this was
basically DC telling us the New 52
Superman is not going to come back and
the reason why we know that is because
with the pre-new 52 Superman he died
fighting uh fighting doomsday all right
he was effectively beaten to death but
we also know that he came back to life
after being placed in a reg eration
Matrix and this is his line of thought
because he came back with a regeneration
Matrix the other Superman can do the
same thing and so he Encounters this new
52 version of L Lang now this is
interesting because L Lang in the pre-
new 52 landscape was a childhood friend
of Superman she grew up with him there
was uh you know romantic tension between
the two of them but nothing ever really
came of it of course we know that he
went with Lois Lane they got married
they produced a child but this new 52 L
Lang is not really the one that that he
remembers she's similar but they're
they're two distinctly different people
and that relationship between the two of
them just doesn't exist anymore but he
tells her that he came back to life
because of a regeneration Matrix and it
stands to reason that the Fortress of
Solitude in the new 52 possesses the
same regeneration Matrix and so when the
two of them travel to the Fortress of
Solitude they actually learn that there
is no regeneration Matrix here and again
this is just DC telling us the New 52
Superman is dead he's gone he's never
coming back and this current you know
pre- New 52 Superman is going to be the
new Superman from this point going
forward now having said that the actual
story that we're going to be talking
about today picks up with this new
Superman and how it is that he relates
to his son Jonathan now I hope I haven't
really confused you guys you know up to
this point in terms of the different
variations of Superman so on and so
forth if I have uh post a comment down
below and and I'll try to clear any
confusion that might exist but with this
uh this this new Superman of course we
have him and Lois Lane and Jonathan
staying isolated but at the same time
this presents a really interesting
situation and the reason why it does is
because for Jonathan he idolizes his
father he knows that his father has
incredible Powers he knows that his
father can do incredible things but the
issue here is that Jonathan himself is
largely restricted in terms of what it
is that he can and can't do now this is
actually a really cool concept the
reason why I like this so much is
because DC does not immediately paint
the picture Superman is great and
Jonathan's going to be great too instead
it humanizes Jonathan as a character
then it tells us much like you or I or
other people who grew up as children we
couldn't just do everything that we
wanted but the idea the purpose behind
you know Superman and Lois Lane
restricting him this way is to teach him
responsibility it's to teach him what it
means to be a responsible contributing
member of society now this does not go
without hard lessons with Jonathan being
told that he should never use his powers
unless he's under the supervision of
Lois Lane and Superman he's initially
hanging out with their cat Goldie and
Goldie's attacked by a hawk and in his
attempt to defeat the hawk his emotions
get the best of him he lashes out he
uses his laser vision and he destroys
both the hawk and Goldie now the reason
why this is a very important moment in
the life of Jonathan is because he's
learning that he has to control his
powers but at the same time he's
learning that he does have powers he
always assumed that he would have the
same capabilities as his father it was
kind of this this you know uh accepted
standard just because of the fact that
he was the son of Superman he had those
genes and it was something that they
told him about when he was younger but
he's at an age now where's powers are
going to begin to start manifesting and
much like anybody going through puberty
it's going to be a very confusing time
for him he's not really going to know
how to handle what it is he can and
cannot do but we're actually going to
find this is going to be a little more
difficult to understand than is
initially being made out to us but the
fact remains that there was actually a
young girl who was named Cathy that saw
him use his powers and so what happens
is later on that night Kathy visits the
home now what's really cool here is of
course when she makes her presence known
when she starts talking to people uh you
know Lois Lane asks whether or not Kathy
has seen Goldie because of course of
course both Jonathan and Clark say no
they don't know where Goldie is and so
Kathy says no she doesn't know either
now she knows that Jonathan killed
Goldie by accident but she doesn't offer
any explanation what's also cool about
this is that when Jonathan's talking to
Clark or talking to his father his
father says the reason why they keep
secret identities the reason why they
keep their names hidden is because in
truth the world had just lost their
version of Superman and for Clark Kent
you know for this PR new52 Superman to
suddenly show up and make his appearance
known would take the World by surprise
now the fact that he has acted has just
drawn the attention because there have
just been people who have seen them at
the same time when the New 52 Superman
died the pre-new 52 Superman was there
he didn't answer anybody's questions
they were all wondering who he was they
were wondering why he looked exactly
very very close to the New 52 Superman
but he didn't as answer any questions he
just basically took off and so he didn't
want to raise a whole bunch of eyebrows
and that's the basis behind this is to
keep Jonathan protected but more so than
that there's a lot of dangerous people
out there and as a child Jonathan just
just doesn't grasp how dangerous the
world can be how bad people can be and
so he just wants to go out he wants to
use powers he wants to be a hero but he
doesn't understand that as a child he's
inexperienced and he could easily be
taken out by somebody or even worse
kidnapped and corrupted by somebody who
would be able to take advantage of his
inexperience with both people and the
world as a whole and so what happens is
that night after going to bed after
being sent to his room by uh by Superman
Jonathan realizes that Batman and Wonder
Woman have turned their attention and
they've begun conversing with his father
now of course because his powers are
fledgling because they're budding and
they're really not experienced yet
Jonathan tries to overhear the
conversation as best he can and the
initial indication that's given to us is
that you know with Wonder Woman and with
Batman and presumably the rest of the
Justice League knowing about this
Superman's existence that they have
questions about who he is they have
questions about his son's Powers the
fact that his son's powers are not
predictable the fact that they're
potentially dangerous and this really
seems to allude to the idea that the
Justice League witnessed the fact that
Jonathan had killed Goldie and the hawk
by accident we don't know if they did or
were kind of left to believe that they
did and knew would Mak sense so they
would be monitoring the family and would
by extent know what it was that Jonathan
had done with regards to that Hawk and
cat but the fact remains they also
become aware of the fact that Jonathan
is keeping an eye on them and so
Superman appears his father appears and
says quickly and quietly you're coming
with me and so what we do is we
transition to an iceberg out in the
Arctic or out in the ocean somewhere
either in the North or the South that's
the only place where you find him and
there is a submarine that seems to have
gotten stuck in this giant patch of ice
maybe a just you know um resubmerged or
I guess you know surfaced uh in in this
s we don't really know how it got there
but the fact is that it's there and
Superman is going to try to get it out
now at the same time this is a
nuclear-powered weapon so there's all
kind of dangers that go along with it
but he's brought Jonathan along for the
purpose of watching now we don't
initially know why Superman committed
this particular act instead of just
teaching Jonathan to do things at home
but the fact remains that Jonathan is
there to watch his father to see how his
father acts as a superhero to see how
his father relates to people now I would
go as far as to say that this has a very
important moral lesson in the sense that
with Superman you know rescuing these
various uh members on the submarine you
know rescuing the submarine itself he
overhears the conversation that they're
having and they refer to him you know is
he the new Superman they're not sure
what his intentions are is he there to
help them is he there to take their
nuclear weapon and use it on somebody in
particular then I would say that the
reason why this was probably done by
Clark Kent is because he wants his son
to realize that not everyone who sees
him sees him as a good guy at least not
yet anyway because they're just not used
to the Superman they're used to the New
52 Superman who engaged in a lot of
violence to be honest who engaged in a
lot of conflict who became doomsday and
laid waste to a lot of what people knew
and loved and kind of betrayed their
trust in in several different forms and
so the result here is that while
Jonathan doesn't necessarily seem to
pick up on this the fact remains that as
Superman is greeting these various guys
as he's talking to them and kind of
helping them get along their way
suddenly the group is besieged upon by
some giant organism some giant monster
and it has a disc attach attached to it
that's controlling it now as far as I've
been able to tell there's no real
indication here on who put that disc
there and what it is that that disc is
you know why why it's controlling that
person and it seems to just kind of be a
a plot device you know but again it may
have been something that I missed but
the fact remains here that uh you know
of course Superman instructs his son
Jonathan to basically help him out here
now this is where things seem to come in
because it looks like Superman is
training his son on how to use his
powers now Jonathan is initially
hesitant here his you know his
experience the last time he used his
heat vision he destroyed Goldie the cat
and he destroyed the hawk and so for him
he's terrified of what he might do that
he might actually kill his father now of
course you know Superman says don't
worry about that he can handle whatever
it is the energy you know uh that that
his son puts off and so Jonathan
basically casts off his code he reveals
his own little Superman uh costume which
is actually really cool to be honest
like the whole you know s and the the
jeans looks pretty badass to be honest
with you guys and he basically fights
alongside his father and he uses heat
vision to destroy one of the discs on
this giant octopus now this right here
is really a Cornerstone this is a
Hallmark of this version of Superman and
this is why DC rebirth is so important
here because in the new 52 like I said
that version of Superman was very
emotional he was very down toe he was
very emo he was very human but people
didn't want that people wanted the you
know the Superman that recognized you
got to do whatever you can to do the
right thing every time you can and
that's a lesson that he passes on to his
son what he says is that no matter what
because Superman himself represents what
people should aspire to because people
on you know on on Earth will come to
look at him as the iconic hero his son
needs to act accordingly because
Jonathan is a reflection of his father
when the time comes when Jonathan takes
up the mantle and becomes Superman he
has to do that in a way that will uphold
the values of what his father stands for
and so this is one of the most important
moral lessons because this is something
that we wouldn't really see with the New
52 Superman and so this is DC kind of
you know solid this is DC telling us
look this is the Superman that you guys
know and love this is the Superman that
you guys are used to this is not just
some random guy but as they're making
their way home we actually find that
there's some sort of organism some
person who's watching these individuals
watching this event unfold and realizes
that Jonathan had accidentally spilled
blood and when he did this Blood had
been detected and it's apparently
cryptonian or at least it detects the
Kryptonian DNA in this blood and then it
says let's travel to the Fortress of
Solitude and so we don't really know who
this or who this person is or what this
organm is at the moment but what we do
here is we transition back to to
Jonathan Kent and Jonathan Kent is
basically hanging out of course with his
uh you know hanging out by himself kind
of taking some alone time I guess to
maybe think about you know the lessons
his father taught him and he's joined by
Kathy now what this portion of the story
tells us is that not all that Glitters
Is Gold and what I mean here is because
we would assume that Jonathan is the son
of Superman he would have all all the
same strengths and all the same
weaknesses that his father has Instead
This is not really the case while the
two of them are hanging out while Cathy
and Jonathan are hanging out with one
another Jonathan accidentally breaks the
branch and goes crashing down to the
ground and ends up going into a
concussion now initially of course Clark
and Lois don't know about this instead
Jonathan is brought to their home by
Catherine and or I guess by Kathy and
her grandfather and her grandfather you
know of course believes Jonathan to just
be an average boy he doesn't know
anything else to believe that he's the
son of a superhero and so you know
initially you know the grandfather uh
you know I guess his name is is cob he
simply just says you know well we could
take him to a hospital we can have
somebody look at him but of course
Superman's like no no no no no we'll
take care of it go home dude like we
really appreciate you bringing him here
and so while Lois is is kind of unsure
about this in the sense that you know
that that Superman's being so protective
we learned that the reason why is
because for Jonathan this should not
have happen Jonathan should not have
fallen you know fallen out of a tree and
been knocked unconscious his durability
should have easily allowed him to
withstand you know a fall from a tree
that was maybe 10 or 15 ft high and so
for Superman something's not right
something's off something is a little
strange but the other thing you guys
also got to keep in mind too though is
that Superman is currently in a world
that he's just not familiar with he's
still learning things he's still
learning what the you know what this
universe contains the kind of things
that function in this universe and so
for all he knows there could be somebody
who's been watching him this entire time
maybe they slipped up and Superman just
didn't know maybe they are able to avoid
his super senses and they just ran up
Jonathan with a chunk of tonight as far
as he's aware that's that easily could
have happened and so he's he's basically
just a parent trying to understand why
his son has succumb to this kind of an
injury and so what we do here is we jump
to uh to The Fortress of Solitude and
with the Fortress of Solitude of course
again something to keep in mind is this
is the Fortress of Solitude of the New
52 Superman and so this is simply this
is not you know the Fortress of Solitude
that we're used to from the pre new52
timeline and again this is why I say DC
rebirth is so cool because basically the
pre- New 52 Superman is adap in into the
role of the New 52 Superman in all its
forms and Fashions whether it ranges
from his friends to his teammates in the
form of the Justice League to even the
places that he used with the Fortress of
Solitude and the gadgets and so on and
so forth but this Fortress of Solitude
is is not being investigated by Superman
himself instead is being investigated by
the same source of energy that had
detected the blood of Jonathan after the
conflict with himself and I guess with
his father and that giant octopus and so
what ends up happening is this being
begins to analyze everything inside this
Fortress of Solitude begins to analyze
the computer system so on and so forth
and when it emerges it makes its
presence known as The Eradicator now
this is why DC rebirth is so
cool because The Eradicator is a
well-known aspect of the DC continuity
he's a well-known aspect of Superman's
history just because his most prominent
role was in reign of the Superman even
though he appeared before the reign of
the Superman event that's his most
prominent role in DC Comics but in the
next video we'll run over that in the
next video we'll cover more about uh
about The Eradicator we'll talk more
about his character and uh and we'll get
into everything that's going on with
regards to him in the new 52 but with
that being said let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
about the son of Superman let me know
what you guys think about him I think
Jonathan's a really cool character I
really like him so far you know he's
struggling to find his place in the
world you know he's the son of a
superhero and he's dealing with the kind
of things that kids deal with you know
and so it's uh it's a really interesting
situation but uh but anyway let me know
and uh I will catch you guys later peace
[Music]